Here’s something to talk about
Every YouTube creator, or, well, almost every
YouTube creator, is faced with a Catch 22
of sorts, a pair of conflicting incentives.
On one hand you have YouTube’s discovery
and ranking mechanisms, for which the key
data points are linked to engagement measured
in percent viewed, likes, shares, and subscriptions.
On the other hand you have the need for a
peer relationship to the audience, or at least
the perception of that relationship.
The first encourages a strong call to action,
openly asking and reminding your audience
to like, share, and subscribe, but this bald-faced
self-promotion is openly at odds with a sense
of approachability, since it pulls back the
curtains, so to speak, and reveals the underlying
asymmetrical mechanics of the relationship.
So, how to resolve this dichotomy?
Well, there’s no one way, but it gives us
a good opportunity to explore the memetics
of advertising by working our way through
one possible solution.
This solution is revelation through obfuscation.
In other words we’re going to reveal the
mechanisms, we’re going to pull back the
curtain, but at the same time we’re going
to put up as many other curtains as possible
to distract from the curtain that we just
pulled back.
Yes, my friends, we’re going into the woebegotten
lands of irony and self-deprecation.
Alright, down to brass tacks, how are we going
to openly ask you, the audience, to like,
share, and subscribe while making it palatable?
We’re going to turn it into a joke.
This joke will make it seem funny, like we’re
putting distance between ourselves and the
incentives that are operating on us, however
the underlying operative and actionable idea
will still be planted and the notion of interacting
with that idea will be recontextualized as
an extension of the joke.
That means you’ll be more likely to like,
share, and subscribe.
So with all that in mind, what if we played
off the repetitive, mantra-like nature of
like-share-subscribe and amped up the almost
cultish reverence?
Like Share Subscribe
That could work.
What if we tried outright re-painting it with
existing religious iconography?
Do you have a few minutes to talk about another
testament of like/share/subscribe?
Maybe not the flavour we’re looking for.
May you be blessed with the peace of like,
share, and subscribe!
Alright, I think we’re on the right track,
let’s take that one and combine it with
the snuggy monk.
Go in peace, my children, in the name of like,
share, and subscribe, amen.
That’s some pretty solid obfuscation, with
a double bonus of creating a baked in atmosphere
of community, vis a vis spiritual initiation.
There’s no accident that so many of the
largest YouTube creators, and community leaders,
have names for their followers.
The Foldable Army, or Team Foldy.
But, this is where it all risks turning into
a quagmire.
It’s really easy to get bogged down in cynicism,
seeing the same actions that are so often
coldly exercised by massive corporations,
and ascribing the same disengaged profit motives
to people who just want to entertain some
people.
The lines get really blurry, was it the chicken
or the egg?
Are we in a space where sincere individuals
are adopting and adapting the exploitative
mechanisms of corporations in order to succeed
in an environment where those are the rules
of engagement, or are corporations hijacking
the emotional structures of authentic community
in order to sell more soap?
Why not both?
How do we tell the two apart, where’s the
line where one grows into the other, and is
it even possible to engage authentically with
another person through a displaced and asymmetrical
medium like YouTube?
Is our cynical resistance to the idea that
we are a marketing demographic breeding an
air of irony that serves to do little more
than prevent us from engaging with content
in an authentic manner, building a wall of
feigned indifference that only separates us
from our true selves, even if opening up would
leave us vulnerable to being exploited by
the capitalist systems that we inhabit, and
in suggesting that we allow ourselves to be
vulnerable am I serving to cut through years
of defensive baggage for our own good, or
simply serving the needs of a capitalist hegemony
by priming you to be more receptive to incoming
messages?
That… is quite possibly something for each
of us to decide on our own, but I would encourage
everyone to avoid becoming too cynical.
We all need to do what we need to do to get
by, and sometimes that means dressing distasteful,
but necessary, things up in a silly costume
and making them do a little dance for our
amusement.
So, go in peace, my children, in the name
of like, share, and subscribe, amen.